ja also es macht ein bisschen kirche die
verwirrung ist zu groß die leute sind
verunsichert bei uns im studio welcher
reporter peter tiede peter jetzt gibt es
ja ein expertenrat eine neue
bundesregierung alles sollte besser
werden und trotzdem sind die leute immer
noch ein bisschen verwirrt sind die
regeln immer noch nicht klar genug also
wenn man auf ganz deutschland guckt dann
sind sie nicht klar genug weil wir 16
bundesländer haben uns 16 länder können
machen was sie wollen oder was sie für
richtig befinden also nicht was sie
wollen aber was sie für richtig halten
und was verfassungsmäßig irgendwie drin
ist und man hat sich geeinigt dass man
spätestens zum 28
zwölf neue beschränkungen eingeführt
also kontakt beschränkung macht treffen
nur noch maximal zehn leute aber da
liegt der hase dann auch wieder im
detail begraben spätestens zum 28 es
gibt bundesländer die einfach
vorpreschen zum beispiel hamburg
brandenburg mecklenburg vorpommern
die un hat und auch noch niedersachsen
diese vorgeprescht niedersachsen führt
sogar eine richtige weihnachtsruhe ein
nachdem heiligabend also je nachdem wo
man wohnt sind die regeln klar aber wir
haben es ja wissen wo man wohnung welche
regeln gerade geben wir haben hier in
diesem studio von olaf scholz das
versprechen bekommen es wird keinen
weiteren lockdown geht dieses
versprechen hat karl lauterbach
gesundheitsminister ebenfalls noch mal
abgegeben wenn sie dieses versprechen
nach deinen glauben halten können
die antwort hat mehrere ebenen also karl
lauterbach hat gestern gesagt hat dass
er nichts mehr ausschließt das ist keine
roten linien gibt dass er arbeitet
momentan überhaupt gar keine möglichkeit
und kann notwendigkeit für einen lockten
sieht die zweite ebene ist dass es
rechtlich momentan nicht möglich ist
also das was wir als lockdown verstanden
haben dass bundesweit die gleichen
regeln gelten bundesweit wird dicht
gemacht und wir haben ausgangs
beschränkungen das ist rechtlich nicht
mehr möglich es kann nicht mehr von oben
per ordre de mufti vom bundeskanzleramt
oder von oder vom bundeskabinett
beschlossen werden das liegt in der hand
der bundesländer da gehört eigentlich
auch hin und das trifft man sich ja dann
zu 16 mit dem kanzler um sich dann
abzustimmen und man hat ein
instrumentenkasten wenn man dann die
ganzen maßnahmen aufeinander stapelt
dann kommt man fast bei einem lock down
raus wie jedes bundesland dann fehlt nur
noch die kontakte schreiben noch die
ausgangssperre die es rechtlich nicht
mehr möglich und von daher die
bundesländer werden jetzt aufeinander
stapeln und wir werden dann lockte
unähnlich zustände vielleicht sehen aber
wir haben ja gute nachrichten wir haben
hoffnung aus großbritannien kommen heute
die meldung dass omikron nach kritischen
studien bei weitem nicht so gefährlich
ist bei weitem milde verläufe hat und
das soll es war ansteckender ist aber
die verläufe wirklich nicht mehr so
schwer sind es kommen jetzt medikamente
auf die auf den markt also sagen wir mal
so es besteht hoffnung und wir sind ja
kurz vor weihnachten und weihnachten hat
man hoffnung und das alte
weihnachtsmotiv fürchtet euch nicht also
vielleicht wird es noch ein bisschen was
gleichzeitig gerade aus großbritannien
auch eine besorgniserregende zahlen
nämlich die rasante schnelligkeit der
ansteckung hunderttausend ansteckungen
dort innerhalb von 24 stunden enorme
zahl ja wir haben uns bei uns gesehen da
liegen wir weit unter der hälfte
momentan ich wollte ich noch fragen karl
lauterbach war immer einer der ja eher
die strengere linie empfohlen hat nur
unser gesundheitsminister wir sehen ein
ihr eigentlich katastrophenszenario das
gezeichnet wird mit omikron der
monsterwelle oder wand die da auf uns
zukommt gleichzeitig sind für mein
empfinden die kontakt beschränkungen die
jetzt da vorgegeben werden ja einen
vergleichsweise kleinere maßnahme und
deshalb hat ja auch das rk ii gleich
dazwischen gegangen und hat gesagt hat
muss alles schärfer und sofort sein
warum ist karl lauterbach jetzt einer
der eher auf der
weicheren linie schwebt man muss einfach
immer genau hinhören karl lauterbach hat
auch früher zum beispiel niemals
schulschließung gefordert als ein erstes
mittel sondern immer dann wenn es nicht
mehr anders ging griff gibt gefühlt und
er war nie jemand der gesagt hat wir
brauchen dringend unbedingt lockte
damals hatte ich mir anders geht da
müssen locker angehen also er war immer
auch ein schritt hinter dem lkw chef
hinterher wieder der da jetzt raus
geplatzt ist mit einem wirklichen
katastrophenszenario und man muss sich
angucken dann bei uns wenn bei uns die
omikron werde dann erwartet wird die ist
ja noch nicht nach und natürlich sagen
die mediziner und sein wissenschaftler
um gottes willen da hinten kommt weiß
wir müssen jetzt schon gesagt die
politik aber nie leute wir können nicht
immer sachen schon auf vorrat machen
sondern wir dürfen rechte und freiheiten
nur dann einschränken wenn die lage
tatsächlich auch schon eingetreten ist
oder wenn sie unmittelbar bevorsteht nur
14 tage bis zur großen omikron wende ist
noch nicht unmittelbar deswegen hat man
gesagt 828 und dann bei karl lauterbach
gehört auch mit dazu dass das ist nichts
ausschließen also wenn wenn es nötig
wäre wenn die wissenschaftliche
notwendigkeit da wäre wenn er die sehen
würde und expertenrat dann würde er das
auch machen oder darauf darauf drängen
dass das jetzt wieder so geändert wird
das infektionsschutzgesetz dass man
bestimmte sachen machen kann also ich
glaube es handelt nur basiert auf fakten
nicht politischer druck beispielsweise
die fdp die ja auch in der koalition
sitzt und daher was lockt bei uns angeht
eine kategorische nein sagen das ist ja
politik also weil sonst könnten wir uns
ja von wissenschaftlern rief dann auch
regieren das und es gibt
unterschiedliche fachrichtungen jetzt
gibt dann auch noch die katastrophe die
katastrophenschützer es gibt da
unterschiedliche fachrichtungen und wenn
du nur auf die virologen höheren würdest
dann müsste es keine politik für die
politik ist dann das abwägen zwischen
dem was notwendig ist und dem was
möglich ist und das was auch
vermittelbar ist und was auch durchsetzt
und das nennt man dann am ende des tages
politik und natürlich kommen da auch
andere sachen als wissenschaftlicher
erwägungen rein aber und drama war das
bisher alles und gefühlt für mich nicht
wir sind einigermaßen gut durchgekommen
und ich glaube wir werden auch jetzt gut
durchkommen das kommt wirklich aus steht
fast ausschließlich gute nachrichten
auch wenn viele infektionen kommen die
verläufe sind bilder es kommt kommt also
nicht in der masse zu schweren verläufen
das einzige problem das wir
wahrscheinlich haben werden ist dass wir
also das was sonst in drei monaten
passiert dann in vier wochen passiert
dass ich das wirklich stapelt und die
quarantäne fälle dadurch das hat die
leute positive abstriche haben so viel
werden dass man bei dass man dass man
den betrieben der kritischen
infrastruktur zu problemen kommen kann
weil er die leute halt zu hause bleiben
müssen mit den angehörigen zusammen ja
da noch in quarantäne müssen das wird
das problem wenn und das hat
gleichzeitig viele leute positiv
getestet sind ob unsere krankenhäuser
dann an die belastungsgrenze kommt das
werden wir weiß man vorher nicht das
werden wir dann so in der zweiten
januarwoche sehen